well and on the original side uh project
yours i'm very excited for is demi monde
uh i hope i'm pronouncing that right
yeah yeah is that still
uh in development is that something that
might be happening soon uh it is we've
we've uh we've had a
a terrific writer's room for about a
year and
we are um to you know
the point earlier about the the pandemic
one of the
sort of remarkable um
and unexpected uh benefits of this
otherwise trying and in many cases
painful time
has been that the projects that that
we've been working on
have been allowed to gestate and
and you know simmer and the writing has
been able to
happen without that more typical
urgency of of pre-production and
production where suddenly
you're looking at locations and
auditions and set design and production
design and props and things
when you're just trying to figure out
the bones and the framework and so
the the beauty of this this time on
demand for example
is we've been able to not just
outline the season but right this season
um and not just
you know roughly understand where we
want to go over the course of the series
but actually plot it out and so i feel
like we're
you know we're in a place that feels
like it you know it should be more the
norm than it ever
is uh to really kind of know where
you're going to go but to your earlier
question that was a really good one
about
about planning things out i just feel
like you know that that's one of the
things that
has you know this time has allowed us to
do in a way that i don't think
we've ever had the uh the luxury before